I try to practice meditating I do
meditate I belong to a martial arts
school a local martial arts school
Bushido Chi and we study study koshish
or a rule which is the old pine tree
school of encouragement with diligence
and self-enlightenment and within that
practice there's the the regular
physical martial arts but we also learn
about traditional Chinese medicine we
also learn about brush calligraphy
philosophy so I'm trying to increase my
daily meditation practice i'm actually
in a taking a class right now at the
dojo where we're looking at shintoism
Taoism five element teachings and the
whole integration of them so the
meditation is something that's a
constant work in progress I dabble so
there was for about a year and a half I
had my camera with me everywhere I went
so that I could capture the moment and
yeah so I I do enjoy doing that I
wouldn't call myself a photographer but
I did do some photography I do some
gardening I love crafts so I do do arts
and crafts my mom actually trained to
teach art and craft as a teacher that
was her specialty area and so we learned
a lot of crafts at home and my latest
craft project was a diaper cake for a
baby shower you know you make the cake
layers out of diapers yeah and we also
learned to do this I don't do to relax
but we also learn to do cake decorating
so like making wedding cakes with all
the layers and the Roses etc that that
has a certain amount of
a certain relaxing quality to it but
it's not something you would do unless
someone actually wanted a cake but it is
it is one of the things that I learned
to do last thing I completed was the
coldest winter ever by sister souljah
I'd heard about that book before and
just wanted something completely
different to read it was cold that
ending was very cold I will admit and I
heard I'd heard a lot about sister
soldier never read any of her work so I
was going on a break and I thought let
me grab a book to read that I've heard
good things about but haven't read the
author before audacity of hope I chose
it because i actually heard barack obama
speak and an event last year and i
thought he had some interesting things
to say i want to find out more so
you